[Musique]
or l'appel par habitude ce paquebot
parce que c'est le nom du fabricant mais
ce sport en croissance pratique est
souvent dans les parcs
c'est le round est le fils est rond sur
lequel on frappe un petit ballon qui
rebondit puis qu'on refera de toutes les
façons le sport est encore un niveau
embryonnaire mais il ya un engouement
incroyable parce que c'est très
accessible
ça serait pas très très vite d'un été à
l'autre au parc jarry qu'un la fin de
semaine donc facilement percevoir 15 15
ensembles de renault selon ce paquebot
il y a quatre millions de joueurs dans
le monde la grande majorité aux états
unis
mais si les règles sont simples les plus
beaux jeux sont parfois la faire de
véritables acrobates
c'est un peu sur le principe du volley
bat donc mais à la place de passer un
gros ballon par-dessus filet ça va être
un petit ballon par le filet je viens de
la balle en jeu
l'optique est pour jusqu'à trois
contacts pour l'heure tourne sur le
filet c'est au québec qu'on retrouve le
plus grand nombre de joueurs de l'en de
n'être au canada un circuit de 9
tournois disputés au travers la province
attire chaque fois environ 200
participants et le québec forme ses
champions rêves de grandeur ça c'est que
ça soit télévisé comme aux états unis en
ce moment ces espionnes télévisée à
quelques reprises des finales collégiale
toussaint nationale fait que ça devienne
un haut niveau la télévision ça serait
vraiment fantastique
les six graffeurs s'investit ainsi
participent à des tournois aux états
unis c'est par passion
certainement pas pour l'argent en fin de
semaine ça aurait valu combien de
victoires
c'était cinq cents us une victoire ici
on parle au niveau national c'est du cap
nella 5000 du s il n'existe pas de
fédération internationale de l'honnête
ni de championnat du monde même si
l'idée semble faire son chemin
ce qui est surtout probable c'est que le
nombre de joie grandissent j'ai jamais
une part spécifique j'ai joué un peu à
bout qui par sa queue baseball hockey
mais le rendement net je pense que c'est
le bon et tout sportif de nature ouais
j'ai fait être karaté hockey
ça peut bien attendre sa tête les coûts
air jean françois poirier radio canada
qu'à mourir